Oh, righteous!
Let me show you something to cheer you up!
Anyway, do enjoy!
Welcome!
Alright, I'm sorry about the trailer.
Little statistical difficulties going on.
But, but, welcome to the I- We're all prepared!
We did 10 tech rehearsals.
You guys were here a week ago.
Yeah, yeah.
And now we're back.
Now we've been locked in for a hot minute actually.
They've only kept us in this room.
Yes, yes, for an entire week.
Minimum water and food.
One apple to share among all three of you per day.
I thought we had a bigger food budget than this actually.
Nope, absolutely not.
Okay, what are we doing here?
We're doing an I Love Japan quiz show, also known as Weeb of
Fortune.
Got all the normies here.
One of them hasn't even been to Japan.
Just found out.
Don't call me out like this.
I think that actually makes things better, right?
Because you're trying to be like, aren't right?
That's, you know, that's a, you're a weeb.
Yeah.
I'm just, I'm just saying that by the way.
I don't know.
Okay.
Don't hurt me like that.
I'm just saying that by the way.
Okay.
I'm Andy.
I'm in the community team at Capcom.
USA and our contestants we have three of them here
technically four technically four who was the fourth one is
it me is it me oh there's two of us yes yes wait I feel like
this is an unfair advantage I have technically five catch oh
this was cute why is it naked is that a question why not why
not can I put this Is it your friend?
Yes.
Is she carrying a sword?
This is my phone of friend.
This is your phone of friend.
Oh, good, good.
Ozzie, that's your phone of friend.
I'm going to give you the wrong answer.
Yeah.
Well, seven.
Like we asked you for a color.
What's going on?
No.
Okay.
Let's meet our contestants.
Fruitcake, do you want to introduce yourself?
And what's your favorite thing about Japan?
Ooh.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Fruitcake.
I am a cosplayer and streamer.
And I play in a lot of monster hunters.
So, fellow hunters out there.
Hello, I'm a great swordmaid.
And my favorite thing about Japan.
Oh gosh, this is hard.
I like that I grew up with a lot of different Japanese
culture stuff, and it got me into cosplay and gaming and
even singing.
So, I would have to say everything.
Everything is the answer.
Everything.
Respect.
All right, Ozzy.
Oh, hi.
I'm Ozzy.
I'm a gamer, a cosplayer, and a streamer, all of which are
derogatory.
And I usually play a lot of Resident Evil, and I let my chat
torture me a lot.
And my favorite thing about Japan has to be the concept of
Japan.
Because unfortunately, I'm something of a larper myself.
I've never been.
So, you know, I got to represent for everyone in Japan.
We'll have to change that.
Are you saying chat has never been to Japan?
How many people in chat have been to Japan?
Yeah, let us know.
Yes.
I'm just saying.
We are going to change that one day.
Yes.
We have to go to Japan one day.
I've been wanting to, like, a bunch of my friends keep on
telling me to come by in the autumn.
It's really beautiful there.
Yes.
Halloween time.
I'm honestly really, really tempted now.
All year round is beautiful.
Other than, like, when it's, like, super muggy.
and everything too.
Yeah, yeah.
And then mosquitoes.
Oh yeah, I don't like that.
No, let's not talk about mosquitoes.
Wait, no one told you about the mosquitoes actually.
There's a lot of mosquitoes.
There's a lot.
There's a lot?
Well, maybe not in Tokyo?
Yeah, I was gonna say, whenever I went there, I've never
really seen any mosquitoes.
During the more muggy seasons.
Also, please look at me when you're talking to me.
I'm looking at you.
And this one.
So you have one eye has to look at that, the other eye has
to look at that.
There's so many things in this video.
Well, there's three of you.
Which one do I look at?
You'd be cross-eyed by the end of this.
Look at all of them.
I don't even know where to put these.
There's already so many things in the studio that are like
catching my attention.
Ooh, apparently people are peaking the mics.
Oh, I think I'm just loud.
We're just loud.
These are sensitive mics.
Okay, let's just talk normal.
Talk normal, but we're weak.
That's true.
I think Louie can kind of fix it in the bath.
Maybe sensitivity?
Fix it in post.
Yeah, is my mic...
Apparently, I'm low.
Oh.
Yeah.
okay I think we can fix it don't worry we're fixing it right
now you can tell it's live because they're fixing it it's
not pre-recorded yeah it's true that's true okay while we're
doing this though our third contestant Doki that's me hello
my name is Doki bird I'm a VTuber I think you can tell
because I'm not real so we're touching you yeah I'm touching
your hair right now and your hair is very nice by the way
very soft this is my 3d for all three of me.
I hope that we're a whole game accent.
And what's your favorite thing about Japan?
Oh, there's so many things.
I mean, I feel like everyone else said everything that's
their favorite, so they stole all my answers.
But, oh, last time I was in Japan, Andy was there.
I was there.
He was there.
We went to the Capcon Street Fighter thing.
Yep.
And I took Andy, just remember, I paid for Andy.
Doki did.
To go to the muscle mommy bar.
What?
I don't even know if you- Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
I don't think we have the clip.
Well, Dope has a clip.
He got a little piggyback ride from one of the- Wow.
Like a squat.
Would you say that's your peak weave experience?
Wait, I said it to Abby.
One of them.
It's more than just a peak weave experience.
Danny!
It's a cultural moment.
Yes.
It's a cultural.
Okay, I will send it.
But to my chat.
That's Andy.
I showed the video to my chat before.
Oh, did you?
That's Andy.
Hi.
I got squatted.
And a guy who lined up three hours for my Capcom jacket.
That's true.
I did it like three times, I think.
Yeah.
Three times for me.
Although she said, she said, can you do 7 a.m.?
And I said, no.
You're like, I was at the last day?
You're real for it.
Absolutely not.
I was like, no, no, no.
I'm not doing 7 a.m.
I did do 8 a.m.
though.
I think, right?
So you didn't want to do 7 a.m.
You did 8 a.m.
He did 8 a.m.
It's just an hour difference.
Yeah, he stood in line for me for two to three hours.
I was like, I'm not waking up that early.
That's a true friend.
Okay, let me see.
How do I send it to people?
I will send it.
I'm so interested.
Capcom USA.
So scared to see this.
That'll be your when you go to Japan, that You have to also
do that.
I mean, I'm up for anything at this point.
Always go for the new experience.
That's true.
You see?
Oh, jeez.
Oh, you're actually doing it?
Oh my god.
Just the one where you got a piggyback ride.
I don't know which one that one is.
Wait, you got a piggyback ride?
Yeah.
Or you gave someone a- I got a piggyback.
From like a muscle mommy that's like, like she goes like
this short.
But she...
She was buff as hell.
hit me too.
Wow.
Yeah.
Pretty cool.
So how does it feel to be God's favorite?
Yeah.
You're the chosen one.
It should have been me.
The chosen one.
That's on me.
I was a little scared though because she was so short.
But then she started like, you know, like, flexing.
I was like, oh, she got it.
Oh, you're actually doing it.
Oh my God.
Roll the tape.
Oh.
Where'd it go?
That was so fast.
Where is it?
Come on.
It was like five seconds.
It's super short.
Yeah, a little bit.
We need it zoomed in.
We got to see Annie's face while it's happening.
He's seeing pure joy.
I was just utter, that's my favorite wee moment as well.
One of them.
One of the favorite wee moments.
So I feel like I deserve like 500 points already for that
experience.
She might get a head startling.
unless you guys want to pay for me to get a squat from a
muscle mommy do i know any muscle mommy personally of course
i do i actually i might know a flight over here right now i
know one who's a monster hunter and they both wait do i know
cosplay ada oh do i know her too i think there might I know
all of you guys.
Yeah, you do.
Do know all of us.
Yeah, I like call you guys up at 3 a.m.
But I don't have any cool videos of you.
Soon.
I only have you beating me in DDR.
Oh, that's true.
I did.
And I feel good about it.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
I hope you do.
I feel really good at it.
I beat you and David.
Yeah, he did.
He's just flexing on his name.
Oh yeah, how's the sound now?
Oh yeah, how's the sound?
I'm also like really loud sometimes.
I like how we haven't even started this.
It's like a little podcast.
It is, it's a podcast.
We'll get to it eventually.
Yeah, but this is our tech rehearsal.
This is the pregame.
Yeah, this is our tech rehearsal.
Congrats, behind the scenes.
Yeah, is it sound okay?
Are we good?
Oh, they're still saying I'm really low.
This is the closer mic check, actually.
Oh, exactly.
This is a mic check.
Sometimes peaks, Joki is low.
Good.
Sometimes peaks.
Okay, I think we're almost there.
We're almost there.
Thanks for telling us.
Hello, hello.
Testing.
One, two, three.
turn me up every time testing testing one two three you
gotta do your nerling my voice I'm so oh sorry I'm so
freaking loud really I feel like I just keep saying I'm low
no I think it's fine better now but crunchy I don't even
know what that means crunchy it doesn't need the clothes
because it's just the pure an adulterated aura.
That's okay, the hair.
Oh, apparently the BGM is loud, too.
Oh, we can turn that down.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think that's probably what it is.
Wait, am I now too...
Oh, now I'm too loud.
We went from one to the next.
It's okay.
I think if we, like, put down the...
Oh, I turned it down.
The background music that I added, like, last minute, guys.
Yeah.
I was in, I was like, maybe we should have some music.
I just went there, added it, and I...
It didn't meet him.
I don't actually know what the music is.
I think mine has a delay.
Oh, okay.
I just picked a track.
I don't know what's happening.
I don't know what music's playing right now.
Yeah, we would find out after the stream.
Yeah.
Or something like genuinely heartbreak.
Oh, this is the saddest music, like piano.
Alright, I think we're good, right?
We're good?
Are we good now?
Okay, we are good.
All right, let's get started.
So this is a quiz trivia show.
We have five categories.
Okay.
We're going to look at the categories real soon.
I kind of baited this with that one.
I know.
We're going to look at it.
Oh.
So the categories are Japanese history.
This is Japanese history and culture.
I'm not going to get any.
Modern history.
Japan.
Modern Japan.
It might be a little hard for the person who's never been to
Japan, but you can figure it out.
You can think, just figure it out.
I'll just imagine everything.
He knows the concept.
Yeah, you know the concept.
Yeah.
You watch a lot of anime and they, you know, they go to,
they're in Japan in anime.
Exactly.
So, you know, there's the Soul of the Samurai.
This is Samurai Facts.
This one is, I'm not going to lie, kind of hard.
Is it?
Japanese language.
It's a little hard.
But, you know, whatever.
language how many people have taken Japanese classes okay
that's just not fair why don't you like change the entire
category I think someone has an advantage that is just not
fair my Japanese teacher is gonna be very disappointed in me
it's it's language that you would hear in anime okay okay
hopefully I that's what I think okay okay where's my VTuber
category and then D-Tuber category.
Really?
That's what Oni Vision stands for.
Yes, no, it's a typo.
It's the Doki Vision.
Okay, Oni Vision, though.
I'm going to show you guys a clip.
It's of Oni Mousha, Way of the Sword.
And you guys don't have to answer a question based off of
your observation of the clip.
Go ahead.
Cool.
Yeah.
Okay.
Before that, this is obviously for Oni Mousha Way of the
Sword.
It's coming out in two weeks.
Oh my gosh, it's a two weeks.
It's two weeks.
It's literally two weeks.
I didn't realize it.
It's two weeks.
September 4th.
It's super cool.
I've been on this project for a while and I can't wait for
it to come out.
I'm so excited.
All right.
Give us leaks.
Exclusive leaks.
It comes out on September 4th.
How does it end?
That's a lot.
How does the game end?
There's an ending.
Yeah.
There's a beginning, middle, and ending.
That's true.
And maybe some stuff in the middle.
We'll see.
Apparently the game, can you confirm that the game does
indeed have a protagonist named John Onimusha?
I cannot.
Yeah.
I try.
Miyamoto Musashi though, that is the protagonist.
And you're gonna see a lot of these questions are gonna be
kind of themed around Onimusha and you'll see, you don't
have to have any knowledge of it, they're just themed around
it.
Okay.
I realize now that I don't know who's gonna go first.
I was gonna like roll a die.
Wait, I was not just...
Or like who goes to yours?
I'm thinking of a number between one and a hundred.
I'm going to say four.
I want to do the meme answer, but I'm also trying really
hard to be professional here.
Wait, actually...
It's not.
No!
It's 41, so Doki, you're the one.
Divided in half, always.
All right.
Are we ready?
Are we ready to...
I'm gonna get...
All of these are bad for me.
All right.
Let's start a Weeb of Fortune.
I realize that Weeb of Fortune is like...
I'm peeking so much.
Weeb of Fortune.
I think weeb of Fortune...
Can I spin that wheel?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's okay.
This is more like Jeopardy.
Yeah.
I think we got the identities mixed up a little bit.
That's okay.
We only watch anime, guys.
I'm here I'm peeking still.
All right.
Okay.
Soky.
I would like to do more...
Modern Japan for a thousand.
Modern Japan for a thousand immediately.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, and you can't answer the question until I read the
entire thing.
Okay.
That's the rule, my last minute rule.
Wait, but then like I chose it so I get to go first.
That's the rule of Jeopardy.
Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah.
What's the point of me?
What is this?
This is not modern Japan?
All right.
So after I read the question, then you hit your buzzer.
I call on you?
Okay.
Polakdo Chinoji Temple acts as the base of operations for
Musashi and his allies before heading out on their journeys.
In modern times, we use airports to head out on our own
adventures.
Name two of the three busiest international airports in
Japan.
What is...
Fruitcake.
Narita and Haneda.
Yes!
Correct!
Good job!
Oh, yeah.
A thousand points for fruitcake.
Okay, see, this is not fair already.
I can tell.
What was the point of me winning the guess the number?
So you can choose.
What was the point?
So you can choose which one you wanted, you know?
Okay, we're gonna update the score real soon.
So first I'm doing this.
So, you know, Louis is doing it all by himself right now.
And David and Michelle are in the back as well.
We're all producing.
Behind the scenes.
Seriously, MVP's behind.
I'm here.
We're all here just here in front.
All right.
Yeah, we're just here to look pretty.
Yeah, that's it.
And be wee.
Are we doing a good job?
Yeah.
All right.
I mean, no, he's always pretty.
I mean, look at her.
There's three of her.
All three, isn't he?
There's three.
Yeah.
She's carrying us right now.
That's true.
Especially the tomato.
Yeah.
That's my favorite.
All right.
Fruitcake.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
I'm going to say Japanese language for...
Japanese language for a thousand makers are going crazy I
think only you might get this one this one's kind of hard oh
this one's kind of high red souls and only we should provide
experience yellow souls provide health blue souls charge
your only armaments how do you say red yellow and blue in
Japanese choose two.
That's right.
Okay.
I know because Aka, because Aka Supa, I, yeah.
Thank you for the Aka Supa.
Thank you.
I've seen your Aka Supas in chat right now.
That is one.
And then I, I, I, I, you got it.
Yeah.
Oh, wow.
That's right.
Done very well.
How did she press the button, by the way?
way you know we have we have like something crazy going on
yeah yeah there's like she is technology yeah i'm literally
red right now technology um for those of you who are curious
yellow is kiiro you might know that what i knew was i'm chad
i might be more cooked in order to know you're these are all
the hard questions right now we're just going crazy we're
just going crazy we're I'm just wild over here.
All right, Doki.
On my turn?
Yes.
All right.
I'll do Modern Japan 800.
Modern Japan for 800.
Musashi can use the East End to dispatch enemies in the
blink of an eye.
What is the Japanese name of the bullet train system that
can take you from Tokyo to Osaka?
I was literally on that train.
Fruitcake.
Shinkansen?
Yes, you were correct.
Oh my God.
I saw you immediately like You're like God I was like Oh God
You recruited one weep And two normies For this quiz show No
it's one weep One normie and one larper It's like the unholy
trinity This might be unfair I wanted to say This might be a
little unfair It's the hard questions you know Where's my
500 point bonus Someone choose a easy one right Okay, we'll
do an easy one.
Okay.
I don't want to say easy because then it...
This is yen, oh, this is yen, 200 yen.
Oh, okay.
Oh, yeah, they're all in yen right now.
Really little.
Yeah, like a dollar or something.
A dollar fifty or sixty or something like that.
Yeah.
What's the conversion rate, Chad?
Yeah, I know.
Yeah, tell us what it is.
I'm really curious.
I want to, I think I'm going to do OniVision for 600.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, OniVision for 600.
So we're going to show you guys a clip once, so pay
attention.
Okay.
Choose once, okay.
Walk in.
The video.
600.
Ooh.
Well, we hear the sound for this, the audio?
There is no sound.
Oh, there's no sound.
Why does he look kind of like me?
Okay, this is a little hard because it is lagging a little.
This is like a...
Let's play it again.
Let's play again.
Yeah, yeah.
frames there so well okay maybe a third time one more time
yeah it's a little laggy okay okay okay it's a little laggy
just a little yeah is it laggy for just us though because
we're like doing this i'm pretty sure it's just for a stream
as well it's for everybody yeah interesting okay okay we did
three times all right question is musashi faces his rival
god rion cube musadero temple here what appears in this
clip.
Ozzy.
It is not yellow, no.
Fruitcake.
Blue?
It is blue!
Good job!
You have to say it.
I only saw the blue.
When you said yellow, I was like, oh no, was there yellow?
Look, I need this to be like a vertical.
I need this clip to be vertical and I need an AI voice right
now for me to focus up.
Musashi faces his rival Gano.
Like how am I supposed to be?
faces off against a metal hat.
Metal hat, what color is the soul that first appears?
Why are you so good at that?
I think we just listened to too much.
Someone has been watching Brain Rot a lot.
I know, that's all I do, guys, is listen to Brain Rot stuff.
Oh.
Yeah.
How fun was that?
You tapped into the only vision.
I tried.
Yeah, yeah, you got it.
I only saw the blue, though.
But that's all you needed to see.
I'm glad you asked that.
If you asked me what were they wearing, what were they...
had no clue.
Go for it.
I am going to do, ooh, let's do Japanese history for 400.
Okay, Japanese history for 400.
This is the Japanese history and culture.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
I think this one's more culture as well.
What do you think?
I think.
Onimusha waithosaur takes place in the Edo period where a
certain noodle made of buckwheat flour was modernized.
What is the name of this noodle?
Aussie.
It is Soba!
Oh, you're on the board!
Oh my God, you're on the board!
Alright, watch me not get a single other one this time.
He only knows the noodle questions.
I'm just happy to be here.
They're all noodle questions.
Every single in Japanese history is just...
I can win!
Do you like Soba, Ozzy?
I do.
Hot or cold?
Both.
I feel like Japanese noodles in general, just...
All of them are good.
I agree.
I don't think I have no bad noodle.
I think I like soba at least hot.
I know, I know.
Is that weird?
That is weird.
It was going to shine, though.
It's because you're the host.
I see.
I'm used to warm.
I'm used to warm and like cold noodles anyway.
That's a controversial opinion you got there.
I know.
So, Joki, you like cold soba?
Yeah, I like cold soba.
they're cold isn't it is it usually yeah usually because you
like i'm on a wave oh my god is it hot that's a hot take you
have there i don't know that's true i've only ever had a
cold but i can see why someone like it warm though i think
it's just more fulfilling for the soul you know yeah soul
like yeah yeah yeah yeah you guys like that okay i think
it's also because it's really hot out too i'm just like more
inclined to go for the cold that's true usually yeah when
you have Yeah, cool yourself down.
Are we Aussie?
Oh, oh no.
You're on the port.
That is.
I actually have to choose something.
I can't just coast anymore.
Do a thousand Japanese history.
You know what?
Do it.
Why not?
Let's do Japanese history.
Japanese history for a thousand.
Wow.
Onimusho, way of the sword, takes place in a period that
directly follows the Sengoku period called the Tokugawa
period.
What is the Tokugawa period's more commonly known name Ozzy
there's probably gonna be wrong the Hayon era incorrect Doki
no I'm a call friend you said call friend I asked I'm a call
friend I'm a call friend give me a sec I actually would not
know this but I would call hello this one hello well wait
sorry wait this is not wait where's my speakers I need to
turn off my headphones yeah just like this is just happening
wait why can't I wait why is it not playing give me a sec
yeah give me a sec I need she picked up give me a Give me
like 10 minutes, guys.
10 minutes.
Should we do in 10 minutes?
Our impromptu day is so bad.
Why is it not picking up?
Hello?
Can you say something?
My phone, a friend, isn't picking.
She picked up.
I'm going to give her five more seconds.
No, no, she picked up.
She picked it up so fast.
Don't do this to me.
No more.
Doki, what's your answer, though?
No!
Answer.
I was just going to ask her.
The answer is no.
That is incorrect, Doki.
No, no, no, no, she's here.
She's here.
Mitt, can you hear me?
Hello.
I can hear you now.
Okay, okay, okay.
Way of the Sword takes place in a period that directly
follows the Sengoku period called the Tokugawa period.
What is the Tokugawa period's more commonly known name?
It's Japanese history.
I messed up.
This is Japanese history.
Oh my god.
Five seconds.
Three, two, one.
No more.
All right.
Fruitcake.
I'm sure it's wrong, but is it Meiji?
It's not Meiji either.
She's just cutting in it.
Oh, I think her internet's shit.
Oh my god.
Sorry.
Is that Sengoku?
Is it?
It is not Sengoku either.
It's not Sengoku.
Okay, so everyone got it wrong.
The real answer is the Edo period.
Oh my god!
Edo period.
Me, you did not know!
Yours sounded very legit though.
Wait, was yours in the Edo period?
What you said?
No, right?
No, I don't think so.
Alright, I'll call you again later.
Just how you should know, I believe, me.
Wait, you're calling me again later?
No, don't worry, next time we'll be Japanese language.
Don't worry, you got this one.
Only one lifeline.
Wait, she gets multiple lifeline?
No, only, you guys can call one person too.
We'll make this, we'll make this.
Okay, but she got it wrong.
So I- No, no, one, one lifeline.
There's my phone.
She got it wrong.
Okay, well yeah, yeah, the answer is the Edo period.
Because the Oni Missoula Way of the Sword takes place in the
Edo period.
Right.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, who's, was it?
Oh, that was mine before.
Shoes, okay, yeah, Aussie.
He's language- Oh, sorry, that's my own video.
Oh, yeah, because no one got this one, right?
Yeah.
No one got it.
I mean, that one was kind of hard.
Yeah, a little bit.
That entire middle category is kind of hard.
Okay, I'm kind of curious about the Soul to Samurai.
Let's do Soul to Samurai for 600.
Soul of the Samurai for 600.
These are all samurai facts.
Oh, no.
I had to Google you guys.
I did not know these off the top of my head.
I only know things that I learned from Roni Kenshin, so...
Samurai like Musashi, follow a moral code concerning
behavior and attitude called the way of the warrior in
English.
What is the name of this samurai code in Japanese?
Ozzy.
Bushido.
You are correct.
Oh my gosh!
Oh, Ozzy.
Yeah.
Ozzy's actually a samurai.
I know.
You're in a sweeper category.
He deserves a sword.
Bushido.
So Musashi, the real life Musashi, didn't really follow that
until like the end.
Bushido kind of was near the end of the Edo period, just
FYI.
I do remember this.
Yeah.
I'm just like reiterating what I googled.
I didn't know this myself.
You're saying it as if you already knew it.
Yeah, maybe I shouldn't have said it.
Musashi is.
IRL Musashi is a very funny person because like he's a
really interesting guy because he's probably one of the most
famous like rage baiters.
Also, isn't he paint too?
Like, did he paint?
Yeah, he painted.
He did poetry.
Yeah.
that this guy has has like been recorded doing like it's
just straight up rage baiting it's actually really funny if
you think about it but it's also just like okay oh
interesting anything for the W I guess that's true I mean he
had like over 60 dubs yeah I mean if you lose and you kind
of die yeah yeah you can't have a loss yeah if you search up
Musashi the Musashi store for the boat or yes I know that
story yes Yeah, where he was late intentionally and then he
turned the boat or into like a sword or something.
He turned the boat or into the sword because he knew that
the guy had like a huge like height advantage.
And on top of that, he made sure that he showed up at this
exact period of time because like he picked this place where
there was like a lot of like the winter was water.
And like at the sun, like what the sun would hit the water
at the exact time when it would blind him essentially.
Oh, geez.
You just smack him on the head.
This is actually, it was really funny.
Aussie's Japanese class.
I know, that's like a tentop.
Yeah, it's like a tentop of like Musashi.
We need to call him Aussie Sensei now.
No, Aussie Sensei.
Yeah, Aussie Sensei.
Aussie Sensei.
I mean, you know all the facts about Oni Mushu Way Disorder
already.
You're done.
You're in a sweetest category.
All right, in the spirit of the samurai, let's do, let's
just sold a samurai for a thousand.
Oh my god.
I can't even remember.
Okay, let's see.
The real life Musashi developed the Nito Ichiriyu method,
which involves fighting with a long sword and a shorter one,
both of which are seen in the game.
What is the name of this shorter sword?
This one's gonna, oh, okay, Ozzy.
I don't remember how to pronounce this.
Where did you get these people?
You were like really close.
I'm trying to wonder if I should give that to you.
You're like really close.
I feel like we didn't get it.
You're really close.
Can you, can you, can you figure it out?
close I'm gonna give you another like another I don't know I
don't remember how to pronounce it you're you just flipped
the syllables you said you said washi zaki wait wait okay
wait wait wait wait wait you got a lifeline to me I'm giving
them lifelines I'm giving them a second chance lifeline
won't even let me call her again she got the answer right
can't call her again oh shit oh I can't remember I don't
know I okay guys I dropped my microphone I'll tell you what
the real answer is and joking fruit fruitcake you guys can
see if you if you give him okay wait wait I should get it if
you're with it so you said washi what say wait I know I it
is hey he's actually no I would give it to him because
that's like something that he probably is the only one that
knew yeah most likely well you said flip it so are we giving
him the points no no I kind of agree.
I can't even call my lifeline.
Let's ask chat.
Let's ask Poland chat.
Yeah, Poland chat.
Poland chat.
Does Ozzy get this?
I kind of agree, actually.
This is for the...
Only because I agree with you.
It's really hard.
I didn't think anyone would get even close.
Apparently, after I dropped my mic, the quality of audio
went up.
It's like...
That's one.
like smacking it's like smacking the TV and it just starts
working better yeah it's like the equivalent of that um
producers in the back what do you think you're guys are the
producers yeah thumbs up or thumbs down either way thumbs up
we're getting them some thumbs ups okay we're giving it
we're giving it to Ozzy yeah honestly you were probably the
only one to get how did you know that Like, yeah, that's
what you said you would live with.
I think you liked that.
Ozzy Sensei, guys.
Okay, let's just say, let's just say, like, late night
Wikipedia binging.
Ah, okay.
He's Googling Samurai facts before he goes to bed.
I actually told him the categories before this.
That's crazy.
So he, I'm kidding.
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
Okay, okay, I was gonna be like, on my stream right now.
I was getting rigged.
I'm kidding.
I was used to participate anymore.
No, that's why I'm like impressed.
I was like, dang.
I have a terrible memory.
I already got my Capcom visit.
I'm going.
I'll see you later.
Took your pictures.
All right, Ozzy.
All right, let's swap this one.
Let's do Japanese history for 600.
Japanese history for 600.
Let's see the question.
Challenged by the Genma, his enemies, and the only gauntlet,
and his uncertain journey.
this is wrong whoops I put this in wrong this is Japanese
language so you chose Japanese language just say that yeah
these are little swips are these are flipped sorry this was
the Japanese language oh then they go back to go go find the
yeah go find history go find the one just just pretend you
didn't see this pretend you didn't see this no one no one
saw this here we go so what what points was that for?
We're gonna just pretend you guys didn't see this one, that
last one.
This is 600.
Tokyo was named the capital of Japan in 1868.
What Japanese city was a capital before that?
Oh no, I'm sure this is wrong.
I think this is wrong.
I want to say Yokohama?
Incorrect.
Doki?
Me?
Oh cool, okay, sure.
I'll just... Random city.
Yeah, random city.
Okay, Osaka.
You might be able to get it.
Correct.
Okay, random city.
Aussie, random city.
I think you might be able to get it.
If you wanted to go to Japan.
Wait, can I do it again?
Can I do it again?
No, we gotta wait for Aussie.
If you wanted to go to Japan...
Kyoto?
It is Kyoto!
Oh my god, that was my second pick.
That was gonna be my second pick.
Aussie Sensei!
Is Aussie winning right now?
Yes.
I think so.
Oh my gosh.
I'm not gonna win.
I'm not gonna lie, I would have, I was gonna guess Osaka.
I was, I was out of Kyoto and I was just like, I was in
Osaka.
It's just because I was in Osaka for Universal, so I should
say.
Universal Studios.
I love Kyoto though, it's like my, it's my favorite.
So I chose Kyoto because the game is set in Kyoto.
The game is set in Kyoto.
It is my favorite Japanese city to visit.
Alright, pick that Japanese language.
Okay, now you know, Japanese language is 600.
Yeah, let's do a Japanese language for 600.
Japanese language for 600.
Get it out of the way.
A challenge, we haven't seen this before.
Challenge by the Genma, his enemies, the Oni Gauntlet, and
his uncertain journey ahead.
Musashi may not know what to do at times.
What is the word for I don't know in Japanese?
Fruitcake.
I don't know.
I don't.
Correct.
I would have accepted a bunch of things.
Like what?
I don't know.
Oh, I don't know.
I don't know this at all.
No pun intended.
I don't know this.
I don't know.
No pun intended.
I promise.
No, she's winning again.
All right, fruitcake.
Just because I think it's so much fun, let's do.
Only vision for a thousand.
The 20 frames per second video.
I know this is really, really slow.
We're going to play it like a bunch of times.
Can you just do your slow mode on the video itself so it'll
catch up to the loss of frames?
practices ahead of time.
No, that's not right.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
What color are the flowers?
Where are they?
Where's the flowers?
Where are...
Can you play that again?
I didn't find the flowers.
No, no, that's it.
That's it.
Okay, we'll read the question.
What color are the flowers in this clip?
Don't give.
I don't even know where the flowers were, to be honest.
I know where they went.
I know.
I want him to play it again.
Nope.
I don't know.
They are yellow, yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Dokey is yellow.
Oh, dokey, you're yellow.
Wait, it was meant to be.
It was meant to be.
I was just like, Yolo.
No, she takes my shot.
She's catching up.
All right, Dokey, choose a category.
uh we'll do this is not fair like everyone else here has
like their category you gotta place your strength there's no
strengths here there's samurai which is yours your wikipedia
binging there's japanese language where we have one person
actually it was like it was it was in high school when i was
doing wikipedia binging nowadays i just pass out i just pass
Japanese history.
Just get all the 800s out of the way.
Let's see the question.
What the?
Brings Musashi to famous landmarks throughout Kyoto.
Which UNESCO heritage site is the most visited temple in
Kyoto?
What?
What'd you say?
Wait, which?
You see that in Japanese?
Yes.
Which UNESCO heritage site is the most visited temple in
Kyoto?
I think if you know any temples in Kyoto, you would...
you might be able to do this one.
I don't know anything about the temple.
Just straight up.
I'm going to give you guys...
Doki.
Doki?
The Kinkakuji Golden Pavilion.
That is a temple.
It is not the right one though.
Kinkakuji is a temple in Kyoto.
You said any temple.
I know, you got really close.
It's the other one.
So when you kind of think of Kyoto temples, it's the other
one.
Any guesses here?
It's a very long word.
Why would you- It's a very long, yeah.
It almost became one of the Seven Wonders of the World.
I visited- Is this the one with the red gates?
No, that is for Shimi Inari.
That used to be a question.
I took that out though.
Oh.
It's not gonna help, but I've been to this temple three
times.
Why is this harder than a thousand point question?
I know.
What is the distribution?
It starts with a K.
Fruitcake.
I'm just pressing it, just to press it.
Okay, there's a word for water in there in Japanese.
Wait, I should get another lifeline.
I should get another lifeline.
No.
I don't even know.
Wait, what do...
Kii...
What do I say it?
Kiyomizu.
It is Kiyomizu-dera.
What?
How do you say?
Kiyomizu.
It's like pretty water.
Not from chat.
Kiyomizu-dera.
That is one of landmarks that Musashi visits here.
Yeah.
Okay, who was it?
It was you, Doki, right?
That was me.
Yeah, okay.
Doki, you choose.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Do we want to take a break?
One, two, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, five, four.
Okay, we're good.
Let's go.
We're too locked in there.
We're too, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, just mess with the flow state there.
Just in case anyone wanted to, like, you know, you can't
mess with the flow state.
Google Japanese facts really quick.
I don't think everyone's up.
Everyone's just there.
Yeah, let me go to the bathroom.
We're off in the toilet just like...
Our Wikipedia's back on the menu, boys.
Samurai facts.
Oh, my God.
Okay, Doki.
All right.
Let's watch our five frames video.
OnlyVision 800.
Okay, let's play the video.
OnlyVision for 800.
Next time we do this, now I know it's like in five frames.
Yeah.
That makes it easier for observing.
Yes, yes.
I don't think so.
I think it makes it a lot harder.
If you want, you can show the question first.
Nope, nope.
Let's see.
Nope.
Wouldn't that be funny?
Okay, here we go.
That would be so silly.
We'll do it again.
Oh my gosh.
I'm already so tired.
Okay.
Let's see the question now.
Musashi meets one of his allies, Izumo no Okuni in this
clip.
It's the girl.
What color is Okuni's choker?
Fruitcake.
Not gonna lie, I'm getting it confused with all the other
stuff that was going on.
She wears so many things.
It is orange.
Okay, okay.
I was like, wait a minute, did I see orange or was that just
the blood on her face?
She had like rainbow, accessories on.
Yeah, she did.
I was getting confused with all the accessories.
I was like, uh.
She had like, initially my thing was gonna be like her
bangle thing, but then she was wearing like 10 things on her
wrists.
So I was like, no, we're doing the choker.
This one, what number was this one?
I have no idea.
800?
I think it was 800.
I think it's 800.
Is it 800?
It's 800.
Right?
I for the word.
Okay.
All right, Ruke.
I think that was 800, yeah.
Yeah.
I guess I should play against, or for my 800 Japanese
language.
This was the special one.
You have unveiled the Tokyo Double.
What?
is the dokyo double so you can here you guys go here's your
uh swords go at it oh that's the dokyo no dokyo is a
character it's it's it's her right there or or yeah dokyo is
dokyo okay so you get to wager before we see the question oh
no you have you get to wager do we how much double or Go all
the way in.
So if I get this wrong, I lose.
Yes, you do lose it.
Let it ride.
No, we're good.
I don't know.
I don't like this.
How much is Japanese language?
But it's a doco double, which means it's like kind of the
hardest one here.
Okay, but she like speaks Japanese.
She does the Japanese.
Do I have to like, do we still have to buzzard in?
No, it's just you.
Oh.
It's just you.
I'm going to do...
You're like the perfect person for this.
I'm going to do four?
This is rigged.
400?
I'm not a gasser, guys.
I can't gamble.
I'm not a gambler.
400.
This is like make believe money.
You're like, I can't lose my fake money.
Wait, it's, it's, okay.
No, my E-Lo.
800.
I know my E-Lo.
Okay, you do whatever.
Do you want it to 400?
Okay, no, we'll make it spicy.
We'll do, we'll do 800.
800.
Okay.
This is just for fruitcake.
I know now.
This is gonna hurt my life.
If you pay attention, you might be able to, you might be
able to figure it out.
Oh.
All right.
Let's see the question.
Okay.
The Onimusha series started 25 years ago in 2001 and
continues on September 4th with Onimusha Wave a Sword.
What does Onimusha mean in Japanese?
I know Oni's demon.
Mm-hmm, that is right.
God, what is Moosha though?
If you think about it, you think about the game.
Wait, what's how much time does she have?
She gets...
How much time?
Until my patience runs out.
Oh, wow.
Okay, so I get time.
15 seconds.
I don't know.
Do you want to phone a friend?
Face off vibes.
They made a trail.
Sure, you can phone a friend if you want.
I don't even know if my friend's awake, but we'll see.
You can phone a friend.
We're allowing you guys to phone a friend.
Okay.
I don't know.
Doki used hers already.
Let me.
Yeah, I used mine on the worst, on the worst question.
You're like, hey, I'm on this random Capcom game show.
You guys can use your lifelines.
Me, I'm in the hole by myself and I'll date myself out.
No.
Ozzie Sensei.
But it's Ozzie Sensei.
And by different, I mean incorrectly.
I think the samurai thing, you got that going.
And by differently, I mean incorrectly.
You got a lot of points.
I think the samurai ones...
I'm actually kind of surprised by that one too.
There's like the other samurai ones are kind of like easy,
such hard.
Wait, is that what I think it is?
We'll see if he picks up.
Oh my god.
Who is it?
Another Capcom creature.
god oh no he might be sleeping though oh no come through who
was it supposed to be can i see it's oh hello oh my god he's
here hello hi riku oh okay you're my phone a friend i need
you to lock in right now okay this is serious riku okay
onimusha what does onimusha mean is demon what does moosha
mean is that your final answer this may or may not determine
if we ever play monster hunter again
she didn't specify which monster hunter is that the final
answer that's your life powder but yes okay that is correct
that is correct hi Riku oh my god thanks Riku I guess we're
playing Monster Hunter again okay love you bye bye Riku all
right 800 points it's a fruitcake good job I thought that
one was kind of hard I'm not gonna lie you did Ozzy you have
a lifeline just saying you do have a lifeline do you need my
phone you want to call Riku again I'm Okay, fruit cake.
Oh, okay.
Lord's first double friend call.
Let's do, okay, let's do Soul of the Samurai for 800.
Soul of the Samurai for 800.
Yeah.
Okay.
I...
This is for Ozzy's.
I know, this is for Ozzy.
Weaky brain.
It's leaking a little bit right now.
Soul of the Samurai for 800.
I know.
It wants...
Okay.
In order to cover his Omni Gant...
Musashi wears a cape-like jacket over it.
This jacket is often worn over kimono.
What is the name of this jacket?
Oh my God, this is hard to me.
Ozzie, what is it?
Is it a haori?
You are correct.
That is crazy.
I'm telling you.
He's actually, he's actually not a haori.
He's a samurai.
He's like lowering our expectations.
I know, what the hell?
He's like, I know.
That is crazy.
He's like, oh, samurai, lord.
I cannot believe like, And like cosplay knowledge actually
kind of came into play.
Oh, is that?
Oh, my God.
He's wearing one right there in the picture.
What is Doki's category?
I'm just here.
Are you guys like Haldi?
Oh, jeez.
I've made Haldi before.
So I do remember this.
Are you serious?
I thought that was going to be like a really hard question.
I'm not going to lie.
Well, I think it is, right?
Oh, this is just a 1v1 at this point.
No, you're doing great, Doki.
No, it's fine.
You're doing great.
You can just strike my name off the overlay.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
For lore that, you know, Musashi, when he gets it on the
gauntlet, he doesn't actually want it, he doesn't like it.
And so he can't take it off, he's trying to get it off.
So in order to cover it, he wears a hollery over it to walk
around.
But then in combat, he, you know, pushes it back so we can
like fight and stuff.
Wow.
Yeah, some lore.
Wow, Ozzy.
It's his version of a sleeper build Kind of pretty much,
yeah.
It's like the shameful sleeper build.
All right, Ozzy.
All right.
That was amazing, by the way.
Thank you.
All right, let's do Modern Japan for 600.
Modern Japan for 600.
I'm trying to get something that everyone feels included
here.
Okay, this one might be word a little weird.
Japan uses more paper to print this word, this word for
comics or graphic novels than they do on toilet paper.
paper.
Fruitcake.
So what is what is the word for comics or graphic novels?
Oh manga.
It is manga, yes you are right.
Does that show you Japanese language?
It's modern Japan, right?
It's just Japanese language.
It's modern, right?
I used to like a lot of manga actually.
Oh, it was a manga collector.
Used to or still do.
Used to.
Now I can't have as many because, you know, I have too many
other stuff.
When I was younger, I had like a whole manga collection.
Did you guys have manga, Doki, Aussie?
I couldn't.
I actually didn't have my own room until I was in high
school.
So I actually did not get to like collect that much like
when I was younger.
So I'm kind of making up for it now.
So now you have manga?
Just the stuff that I find appealing to me.
Doki, do you have any manga?
I did.
I don't really collect them anymore, but I used to have like
Death Note and Oran High School Host Club manga.
Oran High School.
Nice.
That was a good one.
Yeah, so all the manga I got to read was out of order, was
out of order because I always went to the library to like
read.
That was how I could never actually own it myself.
Interesting.
That's how I first found out about manga was at the library.
I think same.
No, no, no, I was an anime club in high school.
I was.
I know, that's why I started learning it.
Anime club.
Anime club?
No, no.
Are you?
No, you only get it if you're an anime club.
I was the anime club.
Nope.
Don't be an anime club.
This is a whole member of the anime club?
I remember the whole member of the anime club.
Yeah, because no one wants to get to it.
What if they bet everything?
We're not gonna bet everything.
She wanted to bet $400 and there was no way for us to beat
her.
Just absolutely absolutely hanging over here.
She weighed the $400 on the Japanese language.
I may be a little bit too competitive.
I am too.
It's okay.
It's the Asian in me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Are I fruitcake?
No.
Oh, wait.
No, you got it.
You got manga.
Oh, wait, I did got manga.
Oh, yeah.
Sorry.
I thought we were so stuck on the samurai thing.
Let's do Let's finish up the Japanese history for 200.
Japanese history for 200.
I just realized we got all the hard...
I know, you guys went the other way.
We're overachievers over here.
All right.
Oh.
Oh, in the real world.
While Onimushu Boy of the Sword may feature a darker
fantastical Kyoto, there is also beauty in the natural side
of it.
In the real world, what is the name of the trees with famous
pink flowers that bloom in spring?
Doki.
I mean, it's a Sakura blossom.
It is correct.
Oh my god, I got this one correct.
I've never actually been to Japan during Sakura season.
Have you guys?
You should, it's so pretty.
I wanna see.
I think Doki you have, right?
Huh?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, Woki.
I'm so jealous.
That's nice.
It's okay, we're gonna bring you.
I mean, they have like Sakura blossom trees and like other
parts of the world too.
This is not just in Japan.
There's like a magic to it seeing in Japan, right?
Yeah, it's just like where it's originally from.
Yeah, yeah.
I know there's that one area in Vancouver.
There's like that one area in Vancouver I'm thinking of.
I don't remember exactly where, but I mean, there's stuff
there in like, I think Seattle as well, but I've never
actually- In DC as well.
I've never actually had anything like that, like
domestically for myself.
I'm just that landlocked.
I think Balboa, I don't know if this park still has it, but
I think Balboa in the park in Cali, they used to have soccer
blossoms I don't know about now oh yeah I don't know about
now I think they either all died or I don't know what
happened guys it was a long time ago when I went I don't
even know what that is I know you know I'll look it up later
yeah Doki oh I just been so long I didn't even realize my
turn I'll, oh my gosh, I guess I'll do a Oni Vision for 400.
Oni Vision for 400, okay, let's see the video.
I was like to choose a question.
I'm so scared to see what I have to observe this time.
I'm probably gonna miss it.
Well, these are the easier ones.
It's like harder than Where's Waldo?
What the, okay.
I need to like, let's play it one more time.
One more time, please.
Like I don't know what I'm even supposed to look at this
point.
Huh.
Oh my god, wait, I got more frames this time.
I know.
Oh my god.
It's getting better and better.
I've got to keep playing.
Let's go for the question.
Got this.
Okay, this ship, this ship, this clip shows a few options
Misashi has in a fight, including deflect and an Oni
armament.
How many Genma does Misashi face when he uses their earth
shakers, the double hammers?
Doki.
I don't know.
I'm guessing.
I think at this point I'll do whatever it takes I think it's
you're gonna get me three it is three yeah I didn't even I
didn't honestly I was throwing a number out there's like I
had nothing to lose at this point like all I saw all I saw
was like the well like the crack was like that little like
crackling effect yeah pretty yeah yeah glass shattering
effect I don't even think about the earth shakers He like
breaks really.
Oh yeah, the moon shatter.
They look like giant maracas.
Kind of.
They do.
Yeah.
They're like double hammers.
Yeah, but they do look like that.
I'd love to see like a version of this game where he uses
those, but instead of like a really earth shattering sound,
it's just a bonk.
Or like a metal pipe clanging on the ground.
That's because I think it'd be funny.
All right, Doki.
The OnlyVision 200.
OnlyVision, let's get these out of the way.
Get the OnlyVision.
out of here.
I don't want to see that category again.
Ducky's over it.
I'm over the five frames.
Oh, the flowers are red, guys.
Flowers are red.
Just be careful.
Let's do one more time.
The flowers are red.
I don't even know what happened.
Oh my god, it is.
Look at me.
This is my bad, you guys.
I don't even know what it has.
It's my bad, and my bad.
I thought it wouldn't lag this much.
It's okay, it feels like I'm back in like 2008.
I don't even know what questions you're gonna say for this.
Is it also lagging on the stream?
Yes.
I didn't realize that.
But they're MP4s, interesting.
Yeah, it is.
Oh.
Okay.
In this clip, Musashi and Rosh Shogun are deep into a fight.
I guess we can put out a shrine.
How many rocks does Rosh Shogun throw at Musashi?
Oh, I don't even know.
I'll give it to you.
Ozzy, you choose.
Doki.
What?
Yes.
Okay, I didn't really count, so I'm just throwing it out
there again.
Two.
Incorrect.
Wow, that was my answer, actually.
I thought you plus or one.
Plus minus one.
I want to say, I think it was three?
It is three.
Why is it three?
I thought it was three, but I was like, there's no way you
put three twice.
That's a C.
I'm like, I'm messing with you guys.
Yeah.
I thought it was four.
That's messed up.
I would have picked three if she got it wrong.
That's true.
But it is.
She should have given it to her.
It's three both times.
Why did you pick me to go first?
It's all your fault, Ozzie.
That is your fault.
Ozzie, Sensei, come on.
This is the shame I will carry for going to ask you.
All right.
I was like, there's no way he puts three, three.
It's like when you take a multiple choice question, and it's
like there's no way it would be two B's in a row.
It's one time in like school.
I hate how relatable that is.
Yeah.
It was like C's like five in a row and we all thought that
they can't be right.
So no one, no one did it.
And then we complained and then our teacher was like, if you
guys actually knew the answer, you would know that it's five
C's in a row.
She pulled that guy.
Yeah.
I'm like, oh my God.
And then you do it.
You continue the cycle.
Why?
It messed with me.
I was like, and next time she's like, it's all A's.
But then, I don't know.
It could be two.
That's messed up.
You continue the cycle.
Yeah, right?
Just rage baiting for that.
Just rage baiting too.
Just for the love of the game.
You actually know this.
That's crazy.
All right, for pink.
Let's do Modern Japan 400.
Modern Japan 400.
Let's see.
You can customize Musashi's appearance and that of some of
his allies.
What is the name of Tokyo's Colorful Fashion District that
is in the Shibuya Award?
Fruitcake.
It is Harajuku.
Harajuku.
That's where you get to see all the cool, like, different
fashion.
Yeah, yeah.
Everyone's all dressed up.
I don't know why I thought of the LA Fashion District.
I mean, close.
I mean, super close.
My brain actually...
I mean, you see a lot of stuff down there.
My brain actually, like, short-circuited her, like, wow, I
can't speak anymore.
All right, fruitcake.
We're almost done guys.
Oh, yippee.
There's still a chance.
Can I give a hug?
Can I share?
If one of us wins, can we share our choosing with everyone?
I never said the prize, by the way.
Oh yeah!
There's a prize.
I don't even, what is the prize?
The prize is bragging rights, but it's also, it's also, you
get like these Japanese sweets and snacks and desserts.
Oh, that's a different form.
Oh, it's so shareable.
It's shareable.
Yeah, it is shareable.
It's up to you.
I don't, you know, it's up to you how nice you want to be.
You're gonna find us underneath this table just like eating.
But you're not allowed, because you're the host.
I'm not allowed to eat it.
I am not.
Because you're the host.
And you did this to us.
I did.
You just wanted to be friends, and then now you had to like
pit us.
I just pitted you guys against each other.
It's okay guys, I got my economy plus on my flight.
It's fun.
I got what I wanted.
Oh no, oh no, oh no.
Just trying to escape, no, no.
Come back.
Okay, fruitcake.
Okay, let's finish up Modern Japan for 200.
Okay.
Musashi faces many Genma who have crossed over to the human
world.
What is the name of Tokyo's famous crosswalk?
Doki.
Shibuya.
Shibuya what?
Crossing.
Yes, Shibuya Crossing.
I was just like...
Shibuya Crossing.
Is that real?
Yeah!
I just know from...
No!
It's a real thing.
I can't believe you were like Shibuya what?
You didn't do that to the other contestants.
Shibuya what?
Yeah!
You didn't do that to the other ones.
I'm ruthless.
I'm the lowest point.
Why?
Because I knew you would get it.
I knew you would get it.
We were in Japan together.
Yeah, I knew you would get it.
We didn't go to Shibuya.
We were nowhere near nowhere near there.
But I knew you would get it.
No, you didn't.
Because I believed in you.
That's why I knew.
he's going for the hard teacher yeah yeah give me god these
are all your categories I purposely avoided them because I
knew I can't get them you might get like Japanese language
easies I think these all four to me are easy all right
Japanese language 400 to fruitcake I guess
Musashi bids his normal life goodbye when he receives the
Omnigone, and he attempts to rid himself of it.
What is the Japanese term for a long-lasting, serious
goodbye?
Doki.
Wait, serious?
There's multiple ways.
I mean, there's a long lasting goodbye.
I mean, there's Sianara.
It is, it is Sianara, yes, it is Sianara.
I was like, is it?
Oh, Doki, Doki!
That was a true question.
She's trying to escape.
Yeah, that's Sianara, guys.
I'm already leaving.
I'm still like He's just like That looks crazy by the way
You're going nowhere You're going nowhere So there's
Sayonara There's like Ja Matan Oh yeah Later Yeah Yeah I Oh
okay But I think you would have gotten Like Sayonara Yeah I
think that would have been That would have been the only one
Yeah I mean I literally had nothing to lose I'm just gonna
start Seeing random answers Maybe you've been getting it
Just start pressing the button Yeah that's literally my
strat I mean I caught up with that Alright Doki Alright
Well, I'll do Japanese language for 200.
Japanese language for 200.
Because I know I'm just 1v1ing fruit at this point.
You can equip charms to Masashi to boost his skills and
abilities.
They also look real cute.
What is the word for cute in Japanese?
Doki.
Kawaii.
Yay.
No, I'm last place.
No!
Yes!
It's okay.
I love the samurai category.
Yeah, yeah, you're in the category, yes.
Yeah.
lost all my lifelines uh all right uh which which sandwich
which do you want which why don't we end the quiz here guys
you know that why don't we i think we're running out of time
i think there's two more i mean we're little we're sort of
uh a little behind schedule it's like 2 a.m over here yeah
you know i'm down to end it guys don't you guys want to get
sushi later at three yeah yeah let's let's do karaoke all
right i guess for a close at the soup store yes yes you guys
want to change games yes let's just change let's change wait
guys i've got a new trailer for onimusha i think we should
play that again no let's not you know we could do a 1v1 in
street fighter i think dopey would win oh yeah i'll take
that i'll take that i can't i don't know
I don't remember the controls.
Alright, Soul of the Samurai for 400.
Wait, no, 200.
200.
Okay.
While Musashi has a range of weapons and only armaments to
use in battle, he most often uses his blade.
What is the popular Japanese term for a samurai's blade?
It is a katana.
Breaking Ozzy Street.
You can only tie with me!
You can only tie!
Oh, it's getting heated.
Alright, it's now fighting for a second.
Oh my god!
Oh, it's time for second, huh?
You're like, first is me.
I got it.
Actually, there might be like...
There's no last place for me.
What do you call that, Tokyo?
Tokyo double.
There's no more Tokyo doubles.
There's no one, there's just one.
There is a final question.
There's a final question.
I forgot that's how Jeopardy!
You can bet as much as you want.
Okay, that's true.
So let's do the last one.
Sold the samurai for 400.
I don't even remember what this one was.
In addition to short-range weapons, a popular and main
weapon most samurai used were called Yumi.
What type of weapons are Yumi?
So in addition to short-range, so this is a long-range
weapon.
What long-range weapon do samurai use?
Fruitcake.
A bow?
It is a bow.
No!
I actually didn't know that.
Thank God.
I'm not last.
Not yet, not yet.
We'll see.
Okay, so that's the end of the categories.
But there is a final cut.
We're calling it the final cut.
We're going to give you guys a chance.
Whiteboards.
Is that why there's three?
Wait, that's not.
Oh, my God.
Whoever gets a second place and third place, I just, you
know...
We should have like...
Like thrown fruit and then just like...
Yeah.
Alright, we'll get you guys some markers as well.
Oh, you got some markers too?
Oh, awesome.
So I'm going to tell you guys the category.
You guys are going to bet how much you want to bet.
You can bet obviously your entire amount or zero.
Up to you guys.
So the category is everyday life in Japan.
Okay, okay, that's alright.
Someone that doesn't live in Japan.
You can do some bets.
Do some bets.
Wait, what the bet before we know the question?
I would bet before you know the question.
Write the bet here.
Yeah, write your bet.
And then I'm going to show you the question.
How many points do I have again?
I forgot.
How much?
I don't actually remember.
How much did Ozzy have?
Ozzy, bet all of it.
I'll bet all my money.
You bet all yours.
You know what?
Yeah, let's do it.
Let's do it.
Bet all your money.
Here's our scores right now.
We should all bet all our money, guys.
oh yeah we kind of like that idea it's just been all our
money guys what is elo okay yeah are we doing that i'm doing
it i'm doing it okay so when i say the question you guys are
going to write it down okay so everyone gets a chance okay
okay the question is for the final cut it's on the way
bottom there we go musashi can roam around the hub air of
kyoto where he can Grits, take on SideQuest and help
civilians.
Perhaps we would have stopped by a local and tourist
favorite if we were in modern day Japan.
There are over 57,000 combini or convenience stores in
Japan.
The biggest three are Family Mart, Lawson, and 7-Eleven.
Rank these in order of the most stores to the least.
So you can get the right answer.
Family Mart, Lawson, and 7-Eleven.
I'm in danger.
The most.
to the least.
I think I know.
The most to the least.
Let me just say it's been an honor, gamers.
You can guess.
I think we're all guessing here.
I made this a guessing one.
It's not even skill anymore.
It's skill.
I feel like I know the first one, but I don't know the
second and third.
I don't know any.
Just based off what I see when I was in Japan.
Okay.
I think I'm done.
You know what?
I might not even know the answer to this one.
I realized that.
I got it.
Because I wrote this one like really last minute.
I think I know the answer to it.
All right, let's do this.
Let me fact check real.
I'm going to step to the side.
No, I dropped my mic again.
I'm like going through my Japan trip.
Give me a second.
I'm already committing.
Either way, it's going to be really funny.
no matter what I get sorry I need a fact-check this my this
is like how do you know if it's like right too I mean really
we don't really know right if I get the zero on this my chat
will never let me hear the end of it I'm gonna be so sad if
change okay okay okay it is what I thought it was also yeah
we don't I'm just looking things up right in ungrouped so
this could be totally wrong I'm worried here is between okay
are we are we are we done yes we go last place first so Ozzy
what is your answer I would like to say it's been an honor
in Jamers oh my I believe I believe he's gonna get it right
after that okay Ozzy said family Mart 7-Eleven then Lawson
that is incorrect so how much did you bet you bet every you
bet every Ozzy a zero oh no Ozzy a zero you know sometimes
David can you bring Doki's board you go big or you go home
what can I say okay this was my strat all along Doki I'm
gonna cover the Doki said Family Mart Lawson, then 7-Eleven.
This is incorrect.
Ah.
But Doki bet.
Doki.
Doki bet.
You should maybe go last.
This was beautiful.
Doki bet $35.99.
Not last, maybe.
Not last.
Doki has one dollar.
We go last there.
That's what he gets.
That's what he wants.
That's right.
Not last.
That's a win for me.
That's a win.
Don't get me playing it correct though.
You are, you are.
Don't get me.
That's a win for me.
All right, fruitcake.
Here we go.
Fruitcake says, 7-Eleven, Family Mart, then Lawson.
This is different from the rest of them.
Yeah.
This is correct.
Oh, wow.
You know what's funny?
I had his answer.
Which is why you did?
I was going through my trip and I was like, wait a minute, I
don't think that's right.
And I switched.
But then I was like, oh.
I'm surprised.
I don't remember seeing a lot of 7-Elevens.
More of the story is, kids.
Life experience is better than lurking.
It is 7-Eleven, then Family Mart and Lawson.
I thought it would be Family Mart because I found me cheeky.
Oh, yeah.
I thought Family Mart would be the...
He's like, I'm cheeky.
Yeah.
There's a lot.
So there's like double the amount of 7-Elevens in the rest
of them than the other two.
So it counts like all of Japan, right?
So even the rural areas, I think it's more likely to be a
7-Eleven.
Oh, yeah.
Because I like in Tokyo.
I did not see a lot of 7-Elevens in Tokyo.
It was mostly family wearing losses.
I could also be totally wrong and I got the wrong
information.
Yeah, you know what?
You could be wrong.
This is all fake, actually.
Yeah.
So, Fruitcake ends with...
I can't believe this.
Yay!
I can say that it would for me honestly everyone bet all
their money I was just gambling on that but I love that
Doki's here for the games though right can we just say the
one dollar oh my god it's that was my plan all along I was
like hoping everyone would pay all their money at one point.
I almost got it.
I almost won it all there.
In third place, we have Ozzy.
I just needed fruits to mess up.
First, can we just say, I'm just happy to be here.
You knew like the most Japanese Japanese.
Yeah, like the samurai stuff.
His cosplay knowledge.
You're actually a samurai reincarnated.
You're actually first place in the samurai category.
samurai this is like the participation award which is like
most important because this is a samurai game this is
exactly maybe you won all along yeah listen this is all
about perspective yes yes anything to say about your about
your not last-place finish you see kids there's a wise man
once said if your next move is if if you don't want to be
predictable then you just make your next move, disappoint
everyone.
I think more.
Okay.
I think your lesson today is don't listen to Doki.
Don't, don't listen.
That's a true lesson.
Lesson of the Samurai.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, don't be that.
Trust no one.
I'm pretty sure Confucius said this somewhere.
I'm pretty sure.
You got second place.
What do you got to say about your second place?
I almost pulled it off too.
I just needed fruitcake to mess up.
You were so close.
You really close.
I see the erasing here.
Yeah, if you made us reveal the answer sooner, I could have
pulled it all off.
I could have had it all.
I could have just cut it off.
Interesting.
And now fruitcake.
You are officially the biggest weeb here.
You get the biggest weeb away.
You've won the I Love Japan Quiz Show, also known as the
Weave of Fortune.
Honestly, she does deserve that.
She's Japanese out of all of them.
I'm like the definition of overachieve in Asian.
Oh, that might be it.
Yeah.
I don't think it's the Weave anymore.
But what do you have to say?
This is your moment.
Talk about your winning moments.
That was very close.
A little part of me wishes Doki.
did bamboozle both of us.
Oh, me too, honestly.
I didn't really know.
That was only you committed to the first choice, if only...
I know!
Imagine if I...
But my intuition...
Maybe I should have just not listened to it.
Did you change it?
Because you looked at Ozzy's like, I don't want to be...
I don't copy him.
No.
I was like...
I literally was going through my Japan trip, and I was like,
wait a minute.
I think I saw a lot of 7-Elevens.
Ah, and then you switched it.
And then I switched it.
I swear in Tokyo, like a couple of years ago, there was a
lot of 7-Elevens, but I felt like there were more Family
Mart as the years went by.
I feel like I see so much Family Chiki and Family Mart
collaborations with other IPs.
So that's why I was like...
That's true.
I don't see a lot of 7-Eleven collabs these days in Japan
versus Family Mart and Lawson.
So I was like, oh, man, if it was 10 years ago, maybe it was
7-Eleven, but I was just like, I don't know.
No.
Okay, well, thank you for playing, guys.
That was fun.
I hope you guys had fun, right?
Doki had fun, right?
I had so, I mean, I'm not last, so yeah.
Oh, that's true, Esther?
I'm not.
All three of Doki had fun.
Almost pulled the greatest heist possible.
Really?
That was really close.
I wanted it to happen now.
Yeah, I think.
Can we like...
We won't talk.
You should have told me it was the wrong answer, just for
the content.
Just for the content.
You should have done it for the content.
She just said wrong.
Yeah, yeah.
Because you weren't going to fact check you.
Nobody knew.
Yeah, yeah.
No one knew the actual answer.
Uh, all right.
So before we end, again, Oni Musha Way the Sword is coming
out in just two weeks, September 4th.
Oh, there was the box right there.
Oh, yeah, there it is.
There's a seal box of it.
Ooh.
So pretty.
It's really pretty, actually.
It's a very pretty game in general.
Yes.
Because it's set, you know, obviously.
in Kyoto.
Oh, we need to give you your gift, though.
You can get your prize.
Ozzy, you get to hand it to...
I'm like, I'm like an Academy Award presenter here.
You're letting the last person hand me the gift.
That's crazy.
Oh, wait, these are kind of...
Are these?
The melancholy kind of crazy, though.
Oh, these are real.
I thought these were squishies.
No.
They're squishies.
I was just about to squish them because I thought they were
squishies.
I mean, it's yours.
You technically can.
These are also very squishy.
Michelle bought these earlier.
What are those?
I don't know.
It's like some kind of jelly.
Oh, how cute.
Oh, it does!
Oh yeah, there's another one too.
This one's grape.
Yeah.
Very nice, very nice, nice, nice.
I will share with you guys.
We all won, so.
We're all winners.
Except for me.
You can!
If everyone wins, I don't win.
Yeah.
That's how it goes.
That's the...
We all unite.
The con is being a host.
Yeah, yeah.
That's okay.
The host can never win.
Yeah.
Have you ever seen any of the game show hosts win?
I feel like they win by embarrassing the other people.
I feel like...
I'm going to say yes.
I mean, we won because he didn't have a seat this whole
time.
I didn't.
But look, I'm trying to like counteract the gamer thing, you
know?
Yeah.
Because I'm sitting down a lot in it.
anyways and he's in costume I'm in costume as well yeah this
is very tight by the way yeah he was like corseting it yeah
it kind of feels like a corset if he sits down it's gonna
explode it's gonna pop yeah internal combustion yeah all
right so that's it thank you everyone for watching September
4th you can pre-order it now if you wanted to there's a demo
out there is a demo out as well Yes.
Super excited.
Thank you guys for coming again and being tortured by this.
We're getting sushi later.
We are getting sushi later.
Yeah.
I don't know what restaurant it is.
David picked it up.
Yes, we are all winners.
Free food.
Thanks, Capcom.
Bye.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
We all have to have a doki.
OK, OK.
All right.
We need to say in the wee boy.
Sayonara.
That's awful.